- Hehehe.
- You really wanna do this, Teamy Bomber?
- I'm coming for you in December...twice.
- Man, these anime outfits are very demeaning.
♪♪♪
- You told me you'd forget to pass.
- I’d explain myself, but this show’s like Cooper…
...one big Rush.
I haven’t had the No. 1 seed since the year I got drafted...
- I was picked before you!
- Bro, everyone was picked before me.
- I'll show AHHHH!
Where's my cool falling soooong?
- I feel like I’m in the crosshairs…
...of the woke anime mob.
- Don’t tell me the playoffs already started.
- You should keep your distance.
- Thought you didn’t believe in distancing.
No, come on. We're in the bounty hunt!
Oh, thank you, little boy.
- Yo, he's actually a baaad adult man.
- It's ours, fam. Wait, woah.
- Micah could become a real member of the Cowboys! Ow!
- That’s right. I, Odell Beckham, forced my way to the No. 1 seed.
Come to—
- Colt McCoy!
- JUST WAIT TILL MY DAD VLOGS ABOUT YOU.
- A meaningless regular-season award? We're on it!
- Just wait till 2017.
Ok, I’m out and they won a Super Bowl, but imagine next year
when they DO have me—
My decision making is SOUND. This will not happen—
Alright fine, I’ll go to the Colts.